[Music]  yes the one and only Ryan Gosling  [Applause]  ryan gosling nabbed an award at  Germany's golden Camaro Awards this week  but look close that's not actually Ryan  Gosling who accepted the la-la-land  honor so this is just uh it's such a  surprise really the impersonator went on  to deliver a whole speech leaving actual  stars very confused I'm Ryan Gosling you  can vine cross time dedicate this award  to you qu and chars confit me yo girl  she knows no I mean I the temptation is  to say something sarcastic the real Ryan  hasn't weighed in on the points yet but  we have to say it's pretty funny even if  the impersonator really doesn't look  anything like Ryan at all the people can  see there were different people and I'll  take that as a win  [Music]  you